it doesn't make you look more masculine
i'm sure
[Music]
okay conor bryan here and he's still on
his phone no i'm sorry that's how
relaxed these sessions are now i know no
i see myself on my phone and i'm like
jesus christ andy put the phone away
okay well i think i'm me saying put the
phone away probably also it's a bit of a
clue
you know
when i say it to you don't say it you're
you know too kind to say it yeah well
i'm glad you put the [ __ ] phone away
anyway conor o'brien here joined by uh
the very distracted andy richter uh for
another
good quick behind the nonsense are those
uh this is where we just talk about some
of our favorite pieces over the years
sitting here with the brilliant uh
hilarious laurie kilmartin uh thank you
for for joining us uh on
this version of whatever it is we're
doing um you did this uh piece i think
we're gonna roll it right now but why
don't you give us a little setup as to
how this came about um i guess we had a
tiny version of the set for some reason
i forget why maybe some advertising
thing i don't know what it was but
no we did it didn't we do like a show
with the tiny set and like shaq was on
and we were sitting on a tiny set no
that i think no no
the set was built for some specific
purpose that
maybe wasn't even going to be used yeah
for the show it was something very
specific that had i think do with tbs
and advertising and then there was this
thought that we could do something with
it yeah just uh a version of the puppy
bowl which was an alternative to the
super bowl for people that didn't want
to watch football so we thought we'd
have puppy conan for people that didn't
want to watch conan
and
it turns out there's a lot of them it
was very important i'm related to a
bunch of them uh all right why don't we
roll this and then we can talk about it
let's take a look
tonight's installment of puppy conan
[Applause]
there's puppy conan
puppy conan is inspecting this puppy
handy
[Applause]
candy puppy conan inspecting the set
just as i do
what
help him out there andy
andy often does the same thing during
the show yeah
there you go oh you saved him that's
nice
take that off
i gotta take my wig off yeah take his
wig off then take your wig off andy
tonight is a special treat we also have
added puppy la bombo let's see puppy la
bombo ladies and gentlemen puffy lip
balm awards
why is his
what
why is his mustache on top of his nose
okay help him out there andy
there he goes he got it off he's good
and of course the special guest on
tonight's puppy conan puppy lady gaga
welcome puppy lady gaga
[Applause]
all right well we have a fantastic show
for you tonight
and uh why a mustache on top of his nose
that makes no sense because he'd
probably eat it otherwise just like the
real labamba okay
[Applause]
so many things i enjoy about that well i
mean obviously uh
you have puppies
yeah and you can't lose you can't lose
and they don't know
they're on television right and that's
one of the joyous things about animals i
can't watch a movie that the minute a
horse comes into a scene no matter how
powerful the acting is i look at the
horse and i know that this horse doesn't
know yeah that it's in an oscar nominee
the horse is just the horse i will say
it always drove me crazy because you
guys both have your two kind animals you
would immediately go rescue the puppies
and i'm like just let them let them hang
out there i just cannot stand there yeah
and watch a puppy struggle for more then
ten seconds and then i'm like okay you
get the [ __ ] idea the puppy's got a
wig on now let that thing go yeah you
know so your tolerance was the lowest
yeah mine was next
and then you had infinite patience yeah
you're a puppy struggling uh i'll go out
of my way to say the puppies were cared
for taken care of uh in every way they
were never in any danger they were
probably humiliated
but they didn't feel any physical pain
yeah they went back to their puppy lives
yeah with a terrible reputation
mocked by fellow puppies fun fact is
that uh puppy andy was adopted by
was it our head writer first yeah matt
matt are you here matt why don't you
come on out and and um he always likes
to be in the limelight
why don't you just stand over here
i'll stay there whatever you know right
here yeah here we go here's good
now now you're away from both
microphones right there there he takes
direction well
you talking about puppy andy
yeah so uh you adopted puppy andy is
that correct we adopted puppy andy after
my wife saw him on the show
and then quick question
the puppies are all identical your wife
saw puppy andy and then saw a puppy
conan
didn't want the puppy conan puppy andy
was her choice she wanted the most
problematic one
i just that's weird to me but anyway go
ahead so uh we brought uh puppy andy
home we named him moose and our dog
callie tried to eat him
within about a week then
andre dubache one of the other writers
on the show adopted him and still kept
the name moose
and now they are kindred spirits well if
you're still watching after that
you really like a deep dive
so puppy andy became moose and went from
matt you don't know you were the one
that picked andre you don't know you
pulled me in i was comfortable what a
tail
oh somewhere in heaven melville is
jealous he didn't think of this
whale of a tale
that's a little insight
get to how insanely unfair i can be
oh boy hey thanks for being here man
you're a good guy yeah thanks i'm glad i
stepped in
i love that we got
some of that insane meanness on it so
come in here and tell us well that's
what happened
how dare you
waste our time by doing exactly what i
asked
oh that made me happy